[Music]
with the release of happy deathday to
you right around the corner I thought
I'd go back and check out the original
film to bring you up to speed with a
story as well as its ending there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you don't
want to know anything about the movie
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to we follow Theresa or tree as
she's known to friends who wakes up in
the dorm room of a classmate named
Carter to discover it's her birthday
tree is a self-centered party girl that
spends the majority of her life getting
wasted at uni and being rude to all her
friends and family she ignores a call
from a father completely dismisses
Carter and throws away a cupcake given
to her by her housemate Laurie she's
also having an affair with her professor
Greg and is pretty much the definition
of white girl wasted 24/7 tree is pretty
unlikable so when she gets lured into a
tunnel and murdered by a mystery man
wearing a mask of the university's
mascot it seems like this is going to be
another whodunit murder movie however
things take a twist when tree wakes up
back in Carter's bed and discovers that
she is living the day over and over
again similar to shows like Russian doll
and movies like Groundhog Day
this time tree avoids the tunnel and
makes it to her birthday party
celebrations are short-lived though when
tree is murdered once more by the masked
man and she wakes up back in her bed
realizing that she is stuck in a time
loop no matter what she does the killer
always finds a way to get here and after
getting some advice from Carter tree
decides to use the loop to her advantage
and find out who the killer is before
she potentially ends up on her last loop
this is because tree begins to retain
damage from her prior deaths so it looks
like things are only gonna get worse
through the film tree lengths to correct
her self-loathing had issued and
relationships most notably the one that
she has with her father we learned that
years ago her mother died and this drove
a wedge between them she seems to have
really grown as a person and then the
movie looks like it's about to wrap up
when the character discovers that John
tooms a serial killer
is being held at the campus
she concludes that this is her murderer
and rushes to the hospital has stopped
him from escaping and killing her in
attempting this though Carter is killed
and trie realizes that she must kill
herself in order to save him she wakes
up again the next day and seems a lot
happier after solving her murder she
ends her affair meets up with her father
and traps and kills tooms in the
hospital ending the day by celebrating
with the cupcake given to her by Laurie
but something goes wrong and trie wakes
up still trapped in the loop she returns
to her room and once again takes the
cupcake from Laurie it's at this point
that she realizes that the last loop was
the only time that she actually ate it
and due to this she died in her sleep we
find out that Laurie was the true killer
the entire time and had not only
poisoned the cupcake but that she had
also used her job as a nurse to frame
tombs for her murder
tree tells Laurie that she will take the
cupcake to the police but before she can
she's attacked by her learn that Laurie
too had been having an affair with trees
professor and that this jealousy has
driven her to murder a huge fight breaks
out entry manages to stop the cake down
Laurie's throat before kicking her out
of a window to her death tree saves the
day and wakes up in Cara's bed after
finally making it to tomorrow which ends
the film so what were your thoughts on
the original happy death day and are you
excited for the new movie comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of last
week's big movie Elita battle angel
which will be linked at the end this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best let's see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]